[Music]
all right so we have a citizen's a Joe
Mallya question I like are you the ruler
Bureau y'all centered all right so
Richard bas honest says how do you know
if the career you choose is the right
career for you and if not do you think
we should change careers to something
we're passionate about yes yes next
question
boy if you go for it right well it
depends I feel like is it making you
happy as a providing everything you need
but then also I think your own happiness
is a big equation on what you want to do
but a career takes a while to get to
right because it's not like a job time
yeah is like are you gonna be happy that
career and then are gonna resent not
doing what you're passionate about same
thing with your passion he could take a
long time get to it but if you know what
you want to do and you can like go for
it I play that's the right move I'm
passionate about [ __ ] but I don't
think it could be a career sure yeah I
don't think so for you or I don't want
to taint it no I don't give [ __ ]
nice mouths are used for many other
things like water art of [ __ ] eaten mmm
I guess that's it I mean what is there
else to life besides [ __ ] [ __ ] and
eatin food
[Laughter]
it already move it on for me I love it
no keep going this is that I don't think
you got a fine passion in your career
per se oh I like it and I don't think
you necessarily need to yeah do what you
love for your career I think it's
important to find a passion and find
something that you do love and then as
long as your career can serve the
passion I think that's what counts it
doesn't actually need to be the same
thing so for example for me I think like
I have a passion for filmmaking but I'm
not necessarily working in the film
industry but I do have a passion and
love for my family and I am able to
provide for that family with what I do
currently with YouTube and stuff like
that and so there's a driving force
there and I think at the end of the day
I'm pretty [ __ ] happy with what I do
right now you know not that I'm giving
up on the filmmaking or anything it's
just I'm not there yet and at the moment
I have found a lot of peace and
happiness before what I do right now so
I think that's pretty cool do these
other things okay have you guys heard of
the concept of a key guy I think it
relates clearly to this it's a Japanese
form of balancing passion work purpose
life goal all this stuff right because
what they figured out is that sometimes
you got to match all four to have this
balance because you have passion mission
or know you have what you're good at
what you have what you love to do will
you have what the world needs and you
have what you can be paid for so we're
constantly looking to be balanced in
this area because if you're too much in
one thing right you don't get it the
other so for example let's say you do
what you love right and maybe you're
good at it so you've got a passion but
the thing is if you're not getting paid
for doing what you love and you're still
broke you're still not paying the bills
right
yeah but if you're good at this and
you're getting paid for this that's a
good profession but what if you're
lacking a mission you don't have a
purpose like you may be getting a
high-paid job like you know you might be
an engineer or whatever but maybe that's
not what your life's calling is right
and so you could be paid for something
and the world needs it but then again
like are you really that good at it
is there passion behind it and so
there's all these things that you're
trying to work at but if you could
balance the four then you have perfect
harmony and you feel pretty happy about
the career that you have so the balance
is what you love what the world needs
what you can be paid for and what you're
good at
dan that sounds that sounds attainable
yeah what I get from this question
though is someone that's like I've
invested so much time possibly so much
money in going in this set career for me
to leave this I'm [ __ ] scared that's
what I get from it I feel like a lot of
people go through that in professional
careers like you have a passion or you
think you have a passion to being like
in the medical field or a lawyer or
something because we have friends that
are professionals that decided to change
their career deep into it right and
you're doing like what eight years of
schooling or whatever and then you start
working as a high-level engineer lawyer
or whatever and then you do two years of
it in your life [ __ ] I don't think I
like this and then you're like I
actually want to open up a restaurant or
I want to be a chef or I want to do
something else that I'm passionate about
and we know a lot of people like that
yeah I feel like I relate to this too
because I've thought about it a lot of
times even in the past like a couple
years of like what if I didn't go this
route like what if I just continued and
wanted to become an engineer and do that
stuff because you know all that kind of
[ __ ] like fascinates me too but I feel
like it I think it depends on what your
final goal is is your final goal that
one career and all your passions the
other line up with our career or is your
final goal that passion and everything
else needs to line up for that because
for me it's I I have my passions and how
can everything else serve that kind of
help Casey was talking about yeah
passions for his family and how else can
his career also support that right so
for me it's like you know
pattern to create things how how can you
change different aspects of your life
including maybe your career to support
your passion rather than going the other
way because I feel like a lot of times
when you have your career as your one
thing you really want to do it could be
really good and that's super successful
but same time it's like then you're
stuck with that one thing right in life
a lot of times it's so complicated where
it's learning also now your career is
tangent to what you thought of when you
went to college right because almost
nobody is there final job is exactly
what they were thinking about in college
yeah right it's always like tangental to
that and I think that follows with their
passion that they had in mind from
college it's just not their original
career idea so then do you think that um
wow this is so sweet I know we could go
back to okay um but then would you say
then what then would you say that the
career even matters would it be like the
mission should be what you're looking
for like what your purpose isn't a
person like everybody has their own like
goals and aspirations and like if they
find that what makes them happy is this
passion then maybe try to find things
that serve that rather than cousin you
know the American mindset its career is
number one it's always your career not
Korea but career mine right it's like
your life needs to be your career and I
think that's a very American mindset but
like a lot of people try to find all
their their end goal and just the thing
that they do cuz you spend so many hours
every week working we might as well try
to kill so many you know birds with one
stone because if you can get fulfillment
purpose everything from like your job
then you're able to knock out a lot of
stuff but I kind of feel like you
shouldn't paint passion with money
sometimes yeah you're [ __ ] right
passion out of it the moment you start
making money with it she comes a machine
and you're like oh [ __ ] the passion has
become a nine-to-five and then you're
like my life is pointless
do you think that that happens for you
sorry do you think that that happens for
you where it's tainted the passion
becomes hated because you're no longer
doing the passion portion of it so let's
say if you're a filmmaker right once you
start making money from it now it's
because you're probably leaning more
towards like the business side instead
of the art side and do you think that's
probably why that is scary part of it
it's kind of like this is the the Avenue
we're taking and then like once you get
your first movie done out of passion I
cool and someone says hey we can make
money with your movie hey you have a
second idea you have a third idea hey
let's put you under contract make five
movies for us and you have deadlines to
meet now and what oh [ __ ] me can I
deliver and then now you're like I don't
know this is so much fun anymore now
it's a nightmare you know and the
passion gets sucked away so yeah it's a
very fine balance there's really added
to it there's also the addition of it
being sacred to you and you're creating
something cuz you like it like if you
create a dish let's say your cook and
you invented it and you're happy with it
and you love it
but let's say now you have to take it
out into the market and you have to
please others within they don't like it
and they don't want you to do it this
way they want it this way now you're not
making art for you now it's a business
you have to make it for them right so I
think that's when things shift but if
you're passionate about serving others
then it's fine you can continue this but
in my case like let's say cooking is
sacred to me and I want to share with my
friends or whatever and I don't cook for
other people then I would be [ __ ]
myself over by becoming a cook at a
restaurant and following my passions
there is I know people who are exactly
like that yeah they only cook for the
family and friends and they're amazing
cooks but that's because they don't want
to ruin it by like and I think people
that's where people and especially young
people get conflicted because they're
like I'm good at cooking I want to
[ __ ] make meals or whatever and then
they they pursue this and then until you
experience that I don't think you
realized oh [ __ ] this isn't for me
because I actually like making food for
myself and inventing things for myself
and I don't want to do it for other
piece
how do you guys define passion like do
you define it as something of a value or
do you define it as like a dream well
yeah because like passion could be
something just like doing that might not
bring you money right yeah yeah I think
passion for me is something that I want
to constantly like be in doing I can't
stop thinking about it like I'm always
trying to sharpen whatever it is that
I'm doing that's like a passion journey
for me it's emotional fulfillment and
self fulfillment so it's a little bit
selfish even if it's something like I'm
doing I'm passionate about helping the
hospitals out right now right but to me
it's still selfish because it serves my
purpose even you know it's selfless but
it's I totally get it like I think I've
had like discussions that this was my
friend where it's just like people who
say like oh boy you're always down to
help others and I was like yeah I'm down
to help others makes me feel good that
fills my knees or me wanting to help
others so in fact I'm being selfish
because I want to do that [ __ ] like I'm
not doing it because I feel like it's a
good thing for other people it's like no
because it makes me feel good to do
pretty annoying you know it's not
passionate anymore yeah I mean like I
like helping people but I'm just saying
like my motives behind it isn't like a
hundred percent oh I'm so selfless it's
like no I'm hella selfish like I do it
because I love helping people yeah I
think passion is one of those things
they can bleed across all your aspects
of life not just your career not just
your hobbies whatever but I can like
yeah it can be so spread out where if
you lose that one thing you still have
it in all the other things you do that's
why I feel like if people make their
career their one thing and awesome we
have this quarantine people are like
what do I do with my life I can't I
don't have that one thing right yeah
these are sense of self
I think what's been working for me is
committing prior what I want out of
something that I'm pursuing so if I if I
say like okay you know I'm doing music
because I want to make an album or
whatever for myself right but if I say
and if it doesn't sell or whatever then
it's okay because I completed one for
myself but if I'm going into it and I'm
like trying to be a megastar then that's
my goal so like people I think they
don't execute with the with the sense of
clear conviction
so if it's like hey I want this career
because what I want out of it is I want
to get a high paid job so I could
provide for my future family or myself
they're not operating with the Y yet
they're they're trying to get too much
[ __ ] out of one thing and I'm like even
when you get into a relationship right
like people aren't clear of what they
want it's like do you want friends with
benefits do you just want a date do you
want to hook up do you want someone to
marry like what do you want out of this
person right a lot of people just get in
and they're kind of like well well kind
of see where it goes and then when they
don't get what they want they didn't
even communicate what they wanted so
that's I think the majority of the world
is like when you're going for this
career you choose if it's the right one
for you not the career chooses if it's
the right one for you yeah so if you
know ahead of time like I'm trying to
make $100,000 from this and I'll deal
with all the [ __ ] because that's
what I want out of it or you could be
like out of this career I want to be
able to help so many [ __ ] people
while I get paid from it and I don't
care if I get paid a little bit or a lot
of it so once you can make that decision
and say that's what I want from it and
stick to it
and once it goes kind of like I don't
want it anymore or whatever then you
switch but you have to make the decision
prior to doing it I think yeah and then
it gets just the final line uh what you
guys all keep saying that I keep hearing
is you just got to try it you just got
to do it try it try a bunch of [ __ ] cuz
that's the we you know if you like it
you don't like yeah I second that yeah
cuz I went into college going in wanting
to be like an animator so I was studying
creatively on drawing and stuff and then
it wasn't until my last year which is
like my fifth year because the program
was five years that like I was like all
[ __ ] I don't really want to do this
anymore like I actually find joy in
production work for animations not
necessary drawing but like the more
logistic sites behind all those things
the discovery wouldn't a came first
exactly and so like as soon as I
graduated I was like pull [ __ ] it's like
I'm screwed because I had no idea what
I'm gonna do but [ __ ] it like I won't
know unless like I actually try and see
where I push myself to and it's just
like the fact that like I had every
intention of still being somewhere in
animation and I knew that I want to be
in production because I've tested it I
was like all production is self
and I was like what can I do in order
for me to achieve that yeah so don't be
afraid guys I think that's what it is
don't be doing
don't make don't be afraid to make
mistakes and it's okay if you don't make
friends I was starting to become a
lawyer for like two years and then
halfway through their program they're
like I want to be an artist and that's
what they told me did ya you're killing
it and they can go the other way around
- yeah try everything